einem russischen forschungsteam ist es
gelungen 24.000 jahre alte rädertierchen
zum leben zu erwecken klingt wie
gruselige science fiction und die große
frage sind wir bald also auch in der
lage komplexe säugetiere eingefroren
über jahre hinweg zu konservieren klicks
umsatz im future lebens dreimal pro
woche spannendes heinz videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
das relative ich ein echter
überlebenskünstler sind weiß die
fachwelt schon lange selbst
sauerstoffmangel extreme kälte oder
trockenheit oder aber lange hunger
perioden machen diesen organismen nichts
aus manche von ihnen fallen in
lebensfeindlichen bedingungen wie etwa
einer dürrezeit in einer art dauer
stadium einer ein geschrumpften trocken
starre in der sie den großteil ihrer
flüssigkeit abgeben sie sind sogar vor
radioaktiver strahlung geschützt jahre
lang insgesamt sind weltweit etwa 2000
arten bekannt die sich teilweise sehr
unterscheiden
die vielzelligen tiere leben
hauptsächlich am und im wasser und
ernähren sich dort von algen und klein
plankton und bereits in früheren
experimenten mit denen 0,1 bis 0,5
millimeter kleinen organismen hatten
diese bewiesen dass sie im gefrorenen
zustand bis zu zehn jahre überleben
können doch das ergebnis der aktuellen
studie top noch einmal alles selbst ein
extremer kälte schlaf von 24.000 jahren
konnten diese organismen überleben
eigentlich ging bis vor kurzem davon aus
dass lediglich viren und einzeller dazu
in der lage sein solche ungewöhnlich
langen ruhezeiten unter extremen
bedingungen zu überdauern
die aktuelle studie ist also sogar für
die fachleute eine riesige überraschung
die forscherin vom russischen instituts
für physikalische chemische und
biologische probleme der bodenkunde
hatten bereits in der vergangenheit
spektakuläre entdeckungen gemacht die
forschenden sind darauf spezialisiert
mikroskopisch organismen aus dem
sibirischen permafrost boden zu
isolieren
dafür sind sie an den entlegensten orten
der arktis unterwegs um dort ihre
bohrungen durchzuführen erst vor drei
jahren 2018 gelang etwas
demnach sollte es gelungen seinen 30.000
jahre alte fadenwürmer nach vielen
tausend jahren im ice zu regenerieren
doch damals kamen zweifel auf die
permafrost probe hatten die vorstände
damals in der sibirischen republik sacha
genommen rund 300 proben hatten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
analysiert und zwei ausgewählt denen
sich gut erhaltene nematoden auch als
fadenwürmer bekannt befanden
eine der proben dieser studie bestand
aus einem permafrost brocken der aus
einer tiefe von 30 metern ans tageslicht
befördert worden war
nach einschätzung des russischen
forschungsteams war dieser permafrost
brocken bereits seit 32.000 jahren
geboren die andere probe stammte nach
angaben des forschungsteams aus einer
tiefe von drei metern und soll demnach
schon 42.000 jahre alt sein
die petrischalen wurden dann über
mehrere wochen bei 20 grad celsius
gelagert und die würmer wurden immer
lebendiger irgendwann fingen die
lebewesen an die nährstoffe aufzunehmen
und sich zu bewegen
sie waren also offensichtlich nicht tot
sondern kryo konserviert heißt also so
viel wie konserviert durch einfriert das
war tatsächlich das erste mal dass
mehrzellige organismen die im permafrost
eingefroren waren wieder belebt werden
konnten so zumindest die behauptung des
forschungsteams bei algen häfen samen
und sporen ist das bereits bekannt sie
können auch nach millionen von jahren in
denen sie eingefroren waren noch
lebensfähig sein
ein österreichisches forschungsteam hat
es beispielsweise im vergangenen jahr
2020 geschafft eine 32.000 jahre alte
pflanze wieder zum blühen zu bringen
es handelt sich dabei um das erbgut
eines nelken gewächses das jahrtausende
im sibirischen permafrost boden überlebt
hatte das pflanzenmaterial hatte in
unterirdischen höhlen überdauert die
wohl vor 32.000 jahren von eichhörnchen
gegraben wurden und als futter versteckt
genutzt wurden mittlerweile lag das
pflanzenmaterial etwa 38 meter unter der
oberfläche des permafrosts bodens der
während der langen zeit wohl niemals
aufgetaut war aus den unreifen früchten
nahmen die forschenden embryonalem
gewebe entwickelten daraus kleine
setzlinge und pflanzen diese dann ein
letztendlich kamen diese dann sogar zur
blüte bei komplexen organist wenn wir
den fadenwürmern hatte man dieses
phänomen zwar auch schon beobachtet doch
dabei betrug die
längste eingefrorene zeitspanne nur 39
jahren auch hier waren sie in aktiviert
und konnten wieder belebt werden
ein ähnliches ergebnis hatten japanische
forschungsteams auch schon bei den
sogenannten bärtierchen diese waren nach
einer konservendose jahren noch
lebensfähig beide ergebnisse reichen
natürlich nichts an die nun vermutete
zeitspanne heran doch wie glaubwürdig
ist dieses forschungsergebnis wirklich
das russische team jedenfalls hatte
versichert die versuche so steril wie
möglich durchgeführt zu haben um spätere
kontaminationen also verunreinigungen
der proben auszuschließen dennoch gab es
weiterhin zweifel an dem ergebnis von
damals vor allem von
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern die selbst nicht an dem
experiment beteiligt waren demnach lässt
sich nicht ganz ausschließen dass die
würmer zu einem späteren zeitpunkt
während wärmeren phasen in angetaute
tiefere bodenschichten gelangt sind
zudem kann auch nicht ganz
ausgeschlossen werden dass die proben
bei der bergung des russischen
forschungsteams damals kontaminiert
worden waren heisst also diese datierung
aus 2018 ist weiterhin umstritten doch
die aktuelle studie aus russland liefert
nun neue hinweise darauf dass nicht nur
pflanzen viren und einzeller in der lage
sind unter extremen bedingungen
ungewöhnlich da geruht seiten zu
überdauern
das russische forschungsteam schreibt
susanne aktuellen studie und den 24.000
jahre alten rädertierchen wir haben
tiere wieder belebt die einst vollmar
musikanten und weiter unsere
untersuchung beweist einmal mehr dass
mehrzellige organismen zehntausende von
jahren bei fast vollständig gestoppten
stoffwechsel überleben könnten bei dem
aktuellen experiment hatten die
russischen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler proben am nordost
sibirischen allersee abfluss genommen
und zwar in einer tiefe von rund
dreieinhalb metern im labor dann die
große überraschung in dem aufgetauten
materia koppelten sich jede menge
rädertierchen aus der gattung a die
nähte als sich die umweltbedingungen im
labor für sie änderten fingen die tiere
sogar an sich zu vermehren die fachleute
reden bei der fortpflanzung ohne
befruchtung von der sogenannten
pathogenese ein kennzeichen der bdi die
relativen eine art die bereits seit
jahrmillionen ausschließlich aus
weibchen besteht und auf das männliche
geschlecht verzichtet mit hilfe der
sogenannten radiocarbon
datierung ermittelten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
das alter der entsprechenden proben
schichten dieses verfahren basiert
darauf dass die menge an gebundenem
radioaktiven 14c atom in abgestorbenen
organismen abnimmt und zwar gemäß dem
zerfalls gesetz das ergebnis die proben
müssen 23 1960 bis 24 1485 jahre alt
sein doch wie gelang es den organismen
solch eine lange zeitspanne im ice zu
überleben
das forschungsteam startete einige
testreihen um genau das herauszufinden
zu frauen sie nachkommen der geborgen
und redet ich noch einmal für mehrere
wochen bei minus 15 grad celsius ein
auch exemplare heutiger populationen
hatten die forschenden im experiment zum
besseren vergleich eingefroren und
tatsächlich hier offenbarte sich das den
rädertierchen die bildung von
eiskristallen beim langsam einführen
kaum etwas ausmacht
nach ansicht des forschungsteams steckt
wohl ein mechanismus dahinter der die
zellen und organe bei sehr niedrigen
temperaturen schützt dazu sagt einer der
beteiligten wissenschaftler stars marvin
das bedeutet dass ein mehrzelligen
organismus eingefroren als solcher für
tausende von jahren gelagert werden kann
um dann wieder zum leben zu erwachen ein
traum vieler fantasy autoren auch höher
entwickelte tiere könnten demnach also
diesen halb lebendigen konservierungs
zustand unbeschadet überstehen
in der fachsprache ist hier von der
sogenannten krise die rede wie genau die
lebewesen solche zeiten überstehen ist
allerdings noch nicht restlos geklärt
möglicherweise macht einen sprung von
wenigen jahren zur jahrtausenden jahren
bei diesen mechanismen auch gar nicht
einen so großen unterschied aus so die
vermutung mancher fachleute
doch klar ist auch hier komplex sein
organismus ist desto schwieriger ist es
auch in eingefroren zu konservieren mit
säugetieren ist das also noch lange
nicht möglich dennoch sieht das
russische forschungsteam einen großen
fortschritt durch die aktuelle studien
dazu schreiben die forschenden von einem
einzeller zu einem organismus mit darm
und berühmt zu kommen auch wenn der
mikroskopisch klein ist ist ein großer
schritt nach vorn in naher zukunft
wollen die forscher nun weitere proben
aus der arktis nehmen um so intensiv
nach weiteren organismen zu suchen die
zu solch einer langzeitcrew bio sie
fähig sind weiterhin könnten den neuen
erkenntnisse auch dazu beitragen dass
bessere gefrier verfahren für
körpergewebe
wie etwa menschliche organe entwickelt
werden chronik tiefgekühlt zum ewigen
leben in diesem video hier gibt es mehr
zum thema wie menschen für die zukunft
sich einfrieren lassen können also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
zwar klicks umsatz im pfizer diesen
kanal dass es kostenlos und geht mit
einem klick auf den abo button hier
unter dem video ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran